good morning good afternoon
good evening good night wherever you are
hello
i'm dave rubin this is the reuben report
direct message
for today april 30th 2021 that's right
it's the last day of april
time just continues to roll by at an
ever faster pace
uh it seems like it was just new year's
and just keeps on going and the crazy
train
just keeps going down the track where it
ends up we do not know
i am back from a couple days in
nashville i was in the free state of
tennessee which was pretty
freaking spectacular i taped uh
candace which is candace owens new show
on the daily wire which
will be up tonight i did the solo
interview so she does
some stuff by herself right at the top
of the show then she does a panel
then there's a 20-minute like private
protected interview that's the thing
that i did uh and that will be up six
o'clock tonight at dailywire.com i hope
you check it out it was just great to
see you know watching candace's
rise has just been incredible one of the
things we talk about uh
i'll give you a little little hint real
quick uh is that candace was on my show
for the first time
in september of 2017. i'm sure many of
you saw that interview at the time we
were doing something called youtube week
where i did five interviews in five days
with
little youtubers little youtubers who
were we just kind of found that we
wanted to you know give a bigger
platform to
and we found this girl known as red pill
black who had done one video
sort of in essence it was about waking
up and telling your parents
that you're a conservative as a as a
black girl and
uh it went viral we saw her we said okay
let's fly out to lay
anyway i sat down with her a minute
before we started that interview
which if you haven't seen you should
watch it will really give you a sort of
feeling of how the world has changed so
much in these
three and a half years since but a
minute before the interview
i realized i didn't even know what her
real name was and i'm turning to my
producer he's going guys
i can't call her red pill black does she
have a real name found out her name was
candace we have the interview
candace and her friend that she was with
actually stayed over
david made everybody dinner we had about
10 hours they stayed till probably like
midnight we taped it about noon
12 hours or so a couple bottles of wine
and a lot of pizza later
and we've just become fast friends and i
mention all this because just watching
her rise
watching somebody go from just a little
youtuber
to literally someone changing the world
someone who has truly
changed the state of the conversation
someone who has walked in the fire
had the mob try to destroy her have all
the stuff with kanye
and then starting blexit and just all of
the stuff that she's done just to become
a complete
great human being and i'm just thrilled
that she's got the show and they have a
live studio audience in there which was
so great to see
real human beings and as far as i know
nobody died during the taping it was
just
incredible uh and you know broadly just
nashville was just wonderful the people
are so nice and great
and happy the whole daily wire team
they're so thrilled to have
left los angeles where i am right now
and be there and nobody's wearing masks
and even when you're at places
you know the hotel where they want you
to wear the mask in the lobby whatever
like everyone basically just has the
mask down and people aren't dying
if they're getting vaccinated they're
getting vaccinated everybody's
gonna be okay we realize the world has
moved forward
and just everybody was friendly and
smiley
and i ate a lot of greasy food i'll get
to that in the q a in just a second
i'll tell you just one other quick funny
thing about nashville so i thought all
right i'm going to be on candace's show
in nashville i'm going to daily wire
shapiro was there by the way i posted
some videos with him
on our locals community but i thought
all right i'm going to get some boots
right i should get cowboy boots to be on
candace's show
so my producer michael and i we walk
down broadway there where they've got
all the all the shops and all the
honky tonks and everything else and i
walk into this boot shop and i'm like
i'm going to get some boots so i see
some boots that i like
try them on well i tried to try them on
i should say
because i realized that i've got
l.a sort of you know tapered i don't
wear slim fit jeans but i wear
you know jeans that you know fit the leg
you can't get boots in those jeans and
now i for the first time in my life
understand really the purpose of the
boot
cut the boot cut is for the boot i never
really put that together
so i was unable to get uh boots because
i didn't want to get new jeans it was a
whole situation we didn't have a lot of
time
yadda yadda watch candace tonight at six
o'clock
and yes today we are doing an ask me
anything q a you guys sent a whole bunch
of stuff uh submitted at
rubinreport.locals.com before we get to
that because you know biden gave
this big speech a couple days ago to i
guess both houses of congress although
there were like four people in the
audience and they're all wearing masks
and the whole thing is ridiculous
theater
i wanted to comment on some of that and
then he gave a speech yesterday in
georgia where he was heckled
and then he was on nbc with more
nonsense about math so we're going to do
a little compilation of
biden stuff right now then i'll get to
the q a first here's just a couple
of the moments that you've you've
probably seen
but i wanted a chance to analyze and
give you my thoughts so a couple moments
from biden's big speech
to congress one day shy
of the hundredth day of my
administration
100 days since i took the oath of office
and lifted my hand
off our family bible and inherited a
nation we all did
that was in crisis the worst pandemic in
a century
the worst economic crisis since the
great depression
the worst attack on our democracy since
the civil war
now after just 100 days
i can report to the nation america
is on the move again madam speaker
madam vice president
no president has ever said those words
from this podium no president has ever
said those words
and it's about time the middle class
built the country
and unions built the middle class
so that's why i'm calling on congress
to pass protect the right to organize
act the pro act and send it to my desk
so we can support the right to unionize
and by the way while you're thinking
about sending things to my desk
let's raise the minimum wage to 15
american families plan will finally
provide up to 12 weeks of paid leave and
medical leave family medical
trickle down trickle down economics has
never worked
and it's time to grow the economy from
the bottom in the middle out
look i also want to thank the united
states senate
for voting 94 to 1 to pass
covet 19 hate crimes act to protect
asian american and pacific islanders
you acted decisively
you can see on television the
viciousness of the hate crimes
ah so much pandering let's do it one at
a time i've
bulleted out some things for you guys
first off uh he talks about 100 days now
you may remember
that joe biden candidate joe biden were
president-elect joe biden said that we'd
wear masks for 100 days
when he was in office these idiots are
still wearing masks the two women behind
him are fully vaccinated he's vaccinated
everyone in that room was vaccinated
they are doing this for pure theater
and clearly they want everyone to be
wearing masks after 100 days he said 100
days that's what he said
a while back then the i mean there's so
many ridiculous signs
to call the january 6th uh capitol hill
attack riots protests whatever you want
to call it to call that the worst attack
on our country since the civil war is is
so
profoundly evil and dishonest and just a
complete destruction of truth which is
everything
that these guys in the media do
constantly now i understand that joe
biden has dementia but i
it seems to me that it is a fairly
severe escalation if he can't remember
911 which was only 20 years ago if he
can't remember that
that's a problem he may want to think
back to
pearl harbor that that was pretty bad
there we also had
jfk was assassinated there's a bunch of
other bad stuff that happened now
we know that nobody even had a gun in
terms of the people that went to the
capitol we know that they actually let
most of those people in and that's not
to excuse anyone that broke the law or
did anything
violent or anything else but if this was
an insurrection as they keep calling it
this was the most pathetic insurrection
in the history of the world if these
people were going to attack the seat of
power
and take over the united states
government they forgot to bring all the
weapons they forgot to have a plan there
was no coordination
it was a bunch of people taking selfies
sitting in nancy pelosi's chair it's
just
absolute nonsense but that's what
they're pushing
then he pretends to care about the
middle class which of course is complete
drivel
because if you cared about the middle
class you would want to cut taxes so
that
new businesses could start and by the
way what you also wouldn't do
is call for a 15 minimum wage because
new businesses
need to pay people less so that they can
grow and then eventually they'll pay
more
and the government has no right to tell
any small business or any business
period how much they have to pay people
so that's just driveless nonsense uh oh
and he wants a bottom out economy that's
what he said
a bottom-out economy except they're the
people at the top they want to control
absolutely everything as he's telling
you he wants a
out economy you want to bottom out
economy get out of the way
let people run their lives go home
nobody likes any of you people
i don't think in the way nancy pelosi
did you see that moment
if you didn't catch it rewind this later
when when he says
you know no we really want a fifteen
dollar
pass a fifteen dollar minimum wage and
nancy pelosi erupts out of her seat
the fastest she's ever is the fastest
she's moved since she was going to get
her next martini
and it's like lady a mad this is a
multi-millionaire politician who just
wants crumbs
for you people as they can use 15
minimum wage to destroy small businesses
because amazon won't have trouble
paying it but the small businesses will
and then in in like the epic pandering
line of course
uh that the kovid 19 hate crimes act
which i don't even understand how those
things got linked together but that's
what he said
uh to protect asian people and it's like
uh actually it's you guys the democrats
the lefties
who are the ones that are fermenting all
the hatred of asian people
because you're the ones that want quotas
in schools as a matter of fact
not only in schools but you're going to
want them in in the government soon
enough there's no doubt that that's on
the way
and as a matter of fact it was democrats
in a completely partisan vote
that uh they were going to pass
something that was going to say
basically be a statement a congress was
going to pass this basically be a
statement
that you wouldn't be allowed to
discriminate against asians in
places of higher education and every
single democrat voted against it
they are voting for systemic
racism that's what they're doing and by
the way
of course they're trying to make this
all seem like it's a bunch of white
supremacists attacking
asian people but you've all seen the
videos and in almost every case
it's black people that is not a
condemnation of all black people
but if you keep telling people that some
people are privileged and some people
are oppressed
they might start attacking those
oppressed people and not all those
oppressed
they might start attacking all those
privileged people and this is
the sort of just disgusting hell that
they've brought us to
anyway biden went to georgia yesterday
and despite
giving the progressives all the red meat
that he possibly could
the protesters there still don't think
he's left enough so he figured out a new
way to pander
take a look i want to thank you the
people of georgia
folks
georgia was uh a hundred days ago today
when i was inaugurated
on the steps of the united states
capitol to be your president
and i was looking forward to coming back
and seeing these guys
i agree with you i'm working on them man
give me another five days
that's what they're talking about
private detention centers they should
not exist and we are working to close
all of them
all right first off you're not going to
believe this we examined the full
videotape he never gave the guy the
microphone he said he was going to give
him the microphone that's the worst
thing you can do by the way if you're
ever on stage you're ever doing stand-up
doing something where you're holding the
microphone
somebody's heck oh can you would you
like to take the microphone no you don't
offer the microphone
and he did not offer the microphone
obviously the guy was chanting
uh about private prisons it was there
was a bunch of stuff it was a little
hard to understand some of it
um that's an interesting debate whether
we should have private prisons or not i
i don't really think we should and we
can probably figure out all sorts of way
ways to commute sentences especially on
low level drug offenses and all sorts of
stuff that has nothing to do with
defunding the police
you guys know my feelings on that but
the last line there was the scary part
the truly radical part and it's such a
perfect example
of what is happening with biden related
to the far left
the far left if you use the use this
sort of as a metaphor what was happening
there there's some guy
screaming about some position that may
or may not be right that's basically the
progressives
all they do is just scream and scream
and scream and then you've got biden
basically pandering to it so at the end
there
he's yelling about abolishing ice and
biden's basically like give me five days
give me five days and we'll take care of
that now we can have a healthy
discussion
about what ice is doing are there ways
that they should be
modified should they not have as much
power
all of that but all right biden just
said it there you go he was going to
give the
guy the mic and then basically announce
that in five days we're abolishing ice
so we'll see about that by the way
there's a couple videos that we're not
showing you over the last few days where
biden
has uh started answering questions from
you know the press when they just start
shouting things and a couple times where
he's actually said i'm gonna get in
trouble for doing this we should have
pulled those up maybe we'll
we'll grab some of them for next week
where he just goes back to the mic even
though it's very clear that his handlers
and whoever's in charge
don't want him answering any more
questions but because he's a little
screwy in the head
and because i think he really does like
talking and perhaps because he maybe
still thinks he's in charge
he goes back and starts answering and
several times
at least twice this week he said oh i'm
going to be in trouble for this what an
odd thing for the president of the
united united states to say
i'm going to be in trouble for this who
who exactly is going gonna
you know make joe biden be in trouble
uh isn't he the most powerful guy in the
room on the
on the earth in the united states
government or perhaps not
uh then he went on nbc yesterday and
talked about masks and uh i'm gonna have
to put my head on the desk for this one
go ahead cdc guidance this week about
outdoor mask wearing
a lot of folks excited that they can now
shed these masks
if they've been double vaccinated are
you going to be one of these folks now
we no longer going to see the president
of the united states outside with the
mascot
sure sure i mean but what i'm going to
do though
because the likelihood of my being able
to be outside that people not come up to
me
is not very very high so it's like look
you and i took our mask off
when i came in because look at the
distance we are
but if we were in fact sitting there
talking to one another close
i'd have my mask on and i met you to
have masks even though we've both been
vaccinated
and so it's it's it's a small precaution
to take
that has a profound impact it's a
patriotic responsibility for god's sake
it's not patriotic joe and i don't think
you know anything about patriotism
anymore and also he completely lied
right there the implication being
that because he's the president that
people are allowed to come up to him all
the time
and it's like actually can you think of
anyone in the country who would have
less people around them who has more
security than this guy
maybe our overlord bill gates but
besides that like
nobody can get near joe biden so the
idea that he has to wear a mask
and there was another video from the
other day where he pretty much admitted
where he walks out he goes to the podium
he walks
he's wearing the mask then takes the
mask off there and it's like he
basically admits
yes this is all theater and that is all
that it is and the idea that him
and the interviewer there that they're
socially dis they're both
vaccinated so you vaccine people are now
anti-vaxxers okay that's what you are
you are far bigger anti-vaxxers
than just regular people who don't feel
like taking the vaccination
right you can judge whether those people
are right or wrong or whether
the science is correct or whatever you
can have all of those discussions
but to have two vaccinated people
still social distancing and not sitting
there with each other
it's it's just absolutely insane and the
fact that you would link it
to patriotism is just also
crazy this has nothing to do with
patriotism what happened to your body
your choice right
i guess we don't mean that anymore right
i thought it was your body your choice
now it's
it's your body our decision something
like that and it's just these people
are just absolutely terrible i don't
like them very much
and now let's do a little q a people i
asked my guys to mix it up today we
shall see what happens
questions of course were submitted at
reubenreport.local
michael asks have you ever been hit in
the head
this is good i see what you did there
have you ever been hit in the head with
a box on a plane
so this was submitted by michael who's
sitting right there my producer you son
of a diddly
uh he said so what happened was we're on
the plane going to nashville
and we're in like the third row and on
in the first row the
flight attendant had the box of snacks
we're on southwest they give you a
little you know it's just like some
salty crap in a bag but she's got the
box of this stuff and she's putting it
up in the
you know a little overhead above the
first seat she actually dropped the box
the box hit this woman in the head she
fell out of her seat
she was like basically unconscious
laying there you know so they were
trying to find a doctor everyone was
trying to figure out what to do
and then in a very odd twist of events
she kind of like it would seem like she
couldn't get up and they kind of moved
her up
they i don't know what happened i don't
want to get anyone in southwest in
trouble
now i'm going to get people in trouble
for this i don't i don't know what
happened exactly
they decided to take this woman's shirt
off so now there's this woman
just laying in the aisle pretty much
like half conscious in her
lace bra then they picked her up
i'm not making any of this up i think
every i think she was fine by the way at
the end
so i don't want anyone to get in trouble
here they put her in the bathroom for
like 20 minutes so you have this woman
who is dazed now in her lace bra
just sitting in the bathroom and i you
know i thought when someone gets hit in
the head with something the last thing
you want to do is leave them alone right
you don't want them to fall asleep isn't
that like a thing
anyway she eventually stumbles out of
the bathroom they had someone switch
seats and she
you know walks down like five six uh
aisles in her lace
bra and she i guess everything worked
out
thank you for including that question
michael okay trish says
what are your thoughts on tim scott's
rebuttal to biden's congressional
address
so we were going to show some of scott's
rebuttal but i wanted to get to the q a
fast tim scott a republican senator from
south carolina
this guy is freaking awesome he is
awesome
and he is telling the truth his rebuttal
was spectacular
america is not a racist nation i know
that the left is trying to make america
a racist nation they're doing everything
they can
and perhaps they're succeeding at some
level um but i thought his
his response about individual
responsibility
about capitalism about the history of
our nation i thought it was
i thought it was honest i thought it was
decent i thought it was good
i'm trying to get tim scott on the show
i would love to have a conversation with
him
by the way tulsi gabriel you know how i
feel about her she sent out a really
wonderful tweet
crediting tim scott for the rebuttal now
she
is at least as far as i know still a
democrat although she's not in
government anymore
and he just retweeted it and it's like
oh maybe we got something brewing now
you got a tulsi tim scott situation now
some now there's some interesting
alliances happening right
that that seems like something and again
imagine if the democrats had gone with
tulsi
instead of kamala like how different the
whole world would feel right now
but i thought tim scott's rebuttal was
excellent i did watch the whole thing
and i also thought that the reaction to
it
was extraordinary so um they basically
had uncle tim trending on twitter and it
was all
leftists saying crazily racist things
about him because they don't believe
that black people have the capacity to
think for themselves and think
differently
than the oh so tolerant progressives do
so when they see a black man
saying some stuff that they don't like
he must be
an uncle tim he must be
worse things than that that i'm not even
going to say right now and they said
some pretty awful things twitter
actually
untrended it they said we're not going
to allow this to trend which in an odd
sense although i don't
you know i'd prefer that they just leave
all of this stuff up i would leave all
of the people up there and leave all the
stuff up
but in odd sense twitter just blatantly
said oh
we are not a platform we are a publisher
because when things trend
that we don't want to trend we can
remove the trends in essence saying oh
we don't deserve
those protections that we got from
section 230
of the communications act so that was an
odd move by twitter
but if you want to see some really
racist stuff by the tolerant of a
diverse crew you should check out some
of the things that mainstream
democrats were saying about tim scott
including joy behar who once was a
decent liberal
on the view who has just completely lost
her mind she's been in blackface by the
way
and she was lecturing yesterday tim
scott on the view
about what systemic racism is and that
he doesn't know what it is so a a white
liberal in blackface is allowed to
lecture
the uh a black southern senator who
happens to be a republican and dares
think for himself that's how ridiculous
these people are ej says that maga
rallies may start again soon
do you see them being even more popular
now that people are waking up i have not
heard that have you have you heard them
is that right really uh that is
fantastic
i am thrilled to hear that i got to tell
you and and i'm sure some of you know
this and we posted some of the video
about it
when i started going to sama rallies
they were doing this weekly sunday rally
in beverly hills and one day
i just happened to be driving home and
passed one i was like all right i'm
gonna go see what it is and i had
i really had no idea what to expect i
really you know you see them on
tv and you see all the american flags
you see all the trump flags and the
interesting cast of characters
i didn't know what to expect and all
that i saw
at every single trump rally was
good decent people and i'll tell you in
beverly hills these were not
traditional conservatives there were
gays and latinos and blacks you guys all
know all that stuff and nobody cared
about any of that
and as a matter of fact there was one
person there who came up to me and said
something about q
and was like running around with the
queue sign and everybody was mocking
that person but i know the media wants
to frame that these were all
crazy conspiracy theorists and white
supremacists it was
it was a true joy and if they do start
them up
again um whether it even the interesting
thing is does it have to have that much
to do with trump at this point like make
america great again
the name trump's not in there the idea
of make america great again
fight for capitalism fight for the
constitution fight for freedom and
individual
rights and and and fight for to retain
the 250-year amazing history that this
greatest country in the history of the
world has
had i will be there i will have fun i
will not wear a mask i will be out with
the people so i'm thrilled to hear that
that's
starting up again and it sounds like uh
it'll be going next month that's great
that's great
giselle says that now that chauvin has
been convicted
do you think that previous criminals
that were arrested by shoving have a
standing to get their convictions
overturned
well i don't want to give you a
completely legal answer on that because
i i don't know like if
it's an interesting technical question
if they convict
a officer for improper behavior
do they get to reopen some of the other
cases to see if that similar thing
happened i don't know if
i don't know what the legal answer to
that is i don't even know you know if
that is that specific to
to a city law or a state law where where
the federal part of that gets involved
my guess is that there's going to be
legal teams looking at that stuff and
and for the record i wouldn't have a
problem
if they go through the proper channels
as opposed to burning down the
courthouses
i wouldn't have a proper i wouldn't have
a problem with them
looking at those cases and seeing if he
did anything that he shouldn't have done
before that all right what do we got
next there vic
says what do you think about the growing
concern that the defund the police
movement may result in some sort of
federal police force so this is very
interesting
because trump sort of hinted at
something like this when he kept saying
if you guys don't defend your cities
then we'll have to everyone kept saying
oh lord here comes hitler right he's
going to bring in the nazi police
they're going to be taking over these
cities now
it's funny because at some level if
you're somebody that lives in portland
or
seattle or san francisco or some of the
places where we really see this antifa
blm violence and and you know obviously
in brooklyn center
in minnesota and in minneapolis and some
of these other places
now it is true that the majority of the
people there voted in progressive
policies and are just getting what they
voted for
um but that doesn't mean that we
shouldn't have law and order and it
doesn't mean that all of the people who
didn't vote for it should be subjected
to the random violence and the
lawlessness
that being said i don't like the idea of
federal troops
you know in essence federal a federal
police force if that's what you want to
call it or the national guard
or whatever mechanism that they would
want to use to get more
federal troops into our states seems
like a very very
dangerous idea like you you don't want
that right we don't want
troops on the streets of our cities and
yet
if the progressives continue to get what
they want which is to defund the police
cause all these police officers to
retire early we did the whole story last
week about the crazy crime rates
that are jumping in every single one of
these cases including murder in all of
these cities
uh right like you trust me you don't
want to go to new york city right now
you don't
i lived there for most of my adult life
i was there for just a couple
hours a few weeks ago in times square it
was legitimately scary
it felt like i am legend it did not feel
like the new york city that i
that i knew and loved for for my whole
life basically
um but is the answer federal troops
and then there's this weird thing which
is maybe this is what the progressives
want
the progressives love power that is
their only quest
their quest is to destroy stuff now so
that there can be enough of a vacuum so
they can fill it
however they see fit so maybe in some
bizarre sense they're trying to destroy
these cities
so that they can go to the federal
government and go to old joe and say you
have to put
federal troops on the ground because
they really really love
power so i would not be for it i don't
like it
and i pray that these cities actually
reverse some of these policies which by
the way they're starting to do they
actually you know at some point the
rubber hits the road
and even for sort of brainwashed
progressives
they do once they really see the numbers
boy you know my whole city is burning
down and
now that i look at the numbers you know
i guess a 400 increase in in murder
isn't great
uh so now they're reversing some of
these policies they're refunding the
police
and even in portland the most bananas
city in one of the craziest states we've
got well even in portland ted wheeler
who has been the
sort of worst pandering progressive to
blm and antifa
in many cases he's helped them uh now
he's pushing back and saying we've got
to figure out who these people are and
we can't have ks on our streets
so you know it's like in many cases a
conservative is just a progressive
who's been mugged by reality and again
when i say conservative i'm always using
that wide sense of conservative
but we're all conservatives now in
essence you want this thing to continue
congratulations you're trying to
conserve the united states of america
and that does involve a little bit of
law and order bing
poppy says what is our canary in the
coal mine moment that once that happens
there's no coming back
that's a good one i had to take a deep
breath on that one that is a good one
you know i think in some respects
in some respects we may have passed it
we may have passed that moment because
the moment doesn't it feel
you know i always say how it's like time
is moving faster now and what we talked
about a week ago
it's like that's already irrelevant
because we move on to the next crisis
and everything else and i think that
that's
partly how it's all designed right now
like our awful politicians
are horrible corporate media and then
algorithms and twitter that make
everything come faster
like we were unable to like see if there
was a true
you know canary in the coal mine moment
a true like this is the warning you all
must wake up to moment well first off
half the country wouldn't believe that
it was the moment the other half
wouldn't believe that the other guys
don't believe it like it would just
there's nothing that we can all sort of
agree on in that sense which
always gets me back to that that local
thing that city thing that state thing
your local community thing
go to a place like nashville where
there's good decent people
who know how to protect themselves i
don't think there is a
canary in the coal mine moment coming
there are little moments you know
just last week we put we posted my
interview with or did we post it this
week actually
man man you travel and there's a lot
going on we posted this week my
interview with paul rossi who's the the
teacher
at grace church school in new york this
is a lifelong liberal at a liberal elite
school in new york city
and then they allow racism under the
guise of diversity and tolerance come in
there and they start telling white kids
how evil they are
and he's starting to fight back so
that's a little bit of a canary moment
for the people at that school that want
to still be woken up or that have the
ability to be still woken up
or who aren't completely brainwashed so
we need
more of these moments but i don't think
that there will be a
full canary moment for the country where
it'll be like holy cow
socialism's here communism's here
marxism's here it's kind of like
it's the slow creep and one of the
things that these guys talk about
is the slow march through the
institutions that they were going to do
this slowly because you can't
just do it overnight because enough
people would wake up if it's one day
everything's fine and the next day
all hell is breaking loose people would
be like whoa we got to do something but
if you do it over the course of years
which is kind of what happened here
a lot of people struggle with that wake
up because people think oh things will
get back to normal and that's why it's
so dangerous
when joe biden oh you know it's 100 days
with the masks and then that passes
and two weeks to flatten the curve and
then that passes like the canaries that
are set up
those are supposed to be the canaries
these moments well you know i remember
back in i mean find the videos of it of
me last april a year ago
when they were like oh california will
be closed until august 1st and i was
like no it isn't
because of course once august 1st
rollers around they're going to extend
that by the way august 1st that was
about nine months ago
and now this buffoon gavin newsom still
has us in this lockdown until june 15th
and we'll see what happens then
right and and de blasio that evil freak
in new york city
he's got them locked down he's now
saying we'll open up on july 1st they're
literally just making up dates
so i think the canary's been shot
basically the canary died of an overdose
and you can't wait for them anymore you
got to figure out how to how to maximize
your life and your family's life and
your values
and your beliefs you got to figure out
how to protect them it's on you
to do it uh lance says why do you think
the left places more emphasis on the
spectrum of
gender and not race this is an
interesting question and it's like you
know
they're really black and white when it
comes to race right you're either black
or white and if you're black
you're oppressed and if you're white
you're the oppressor but when it comes
to gender there's a gajillion genders
and we can choose all the genders and
you can wake up one day and be another
gender and you can change your
your ids and all of that stuff so
they're very black
and white when it comes to one thing
and then they're very not black and
white no pun intended when it comes to
the other
um you know i think it's partly because
they've used gender
well i'll answer it this way actually i
think it's partly because they've used
race first as the ultimate crudgel it's
the one that you can just see just like
that oh that's a black person that's a
white person now of course the irony to
that
is there's many mixed people barack
obama our president who the progressives
will
will learn to hate over time um you know
his mother
was white his father was black it was
very obvious that he id he
visually i suppose looked more uh black
but you know a lot of people thought he
talked white so what do we do with this
confusing mess of things you know
frankly i don't care about either of
those things uh you either believe that
the beliefs and policies he was putting
into place were good or not
at the time i kind of thought that they
were and i voted for the guy twice and i
regret it and i apologize and if i can
send you all a dollar or two
you just let me know um but they've
looked at gender because it's sort of
thought of as the obvious one where the
uh sorry race says the obvious one where
gender becomes this other thing you know
you're a boy you identify as a girl
you're
trans or you want to dress this way or
whatever
all of that stuff is and this is why
the trans issue has become what i would
say is it's it's become
sort of this this crazy vehicle
for a lot of other stuff so i'll do the
part so you losers
at media matters when you clip this
video it's just going to be out there
i'll do the part
with the caveats which is that i want
people to live whatever life they want
to live i don't care if anyone's trans
gendered and if you are an adult and you
want to transition that's fine i don't
think the government has to pay for it i
don't think your employer has to pay for
it and i certainly don't think children
should be doing it and i know that all
makes me a right-wing racist
but that's just my personal belief on
that uh thank you very much
but you can do whatever you want as an
adult you cannot have a situation which
is where we're headed right now
we're going to be teaching this stuff in
schools we're going to be then i mean
we will get to the point i guarantee
this is what the progressives want
with everything we will get to the point
where five-year-olds at schools are
going to say i want to be the other
gender my parents won't let me be there
and then teachers are going to be
reporting parents
and we will have some sort of social
services that are going to try to take
parents away from kids
i think there's even a case of that
happening in canada right now there is
no there there you understand there's no
bottom to the endless pit that the left
is bringing us that they're pushing us
all into
they're pushing us into a pit and you
know if the pit had a bottom a 10 foot
bottom
at some point we'd be able to climb out
of it but they're pushing us into a
bottomless pit
and that is why this thing is so
dangerous that by the way
if you haven't read it uh douglas
murray's last book the madness of crowds
and douglas is one of the
one of the great thinkers i would say
the great conservative thinkers we have
on planet earth
uh he is a british conservative he so
happens to be gay
um and i think that we've talked about
it actually that perhaps
gives him a little extra insight into
some of this stuff
right you're a little more sensitive to
some of this stuff but in the madness of
crowds one of the great things that he
does in the book
is he separates the gay rights issue
which was
a a march for equality right it was a
march for
can we enter the same contracts as
heterosexual people
meaning can we get married and and by
the way marriage and then family are the
basic building blocks of
western civilization so these are things
that i believe
that if you're a true conservative you
should be for you're still entitled to
your
private religious beliefs on whatever
you may think about homosexuality or
anything else but you in essence
want people to be able to build families
that's a that's a key thing
right to the operation of a flourishing
society
what douglas did in his book is he
separates
the gay issue and the gay rights issue
from the trans issue which is a very
very different beast than you can see it
just bursting forth
throughout society all right let me go a
little quicker here jay says you still
owe us a book tour
we can call it be free to breathe tour
when you come to texas again
yes you know by the way don't burn this
book came out a year ago
two days ago wednesday it was a year
it's a crap i mean that's how fast time
flies
absolutely crazy i was supposed to be on
a book tour we were doing like 40 u.s
cities and then i was going to go to
i was going to go to europe we were
going to eastern europe and western
europe i was going to go to australia
and all these things we're working on it
uh as i told you guys a week or so ago i
just handed in my second manuscript so
my next book
which we'll announce over the next
couple of weeks will be out i believe in
april of next year so
one year from now which is a kind of
funny thing about the publishing process
like the ideas that i included in this
book that i just finished
they're going to be all hot a year from
now because that's when i'll do all the
press about them
that's what it'll all be being talked
about and that's one of the weird things
about writing books it's just sort of a
the machinery around it is kind of old
because i would love to get these
you know these are ideas that i talk
about now but like the world kind of
catches up in a later so as my
my friend andrew who i used to write
comedy with used to say to me dave we're
so ahead of the curve we're behind it
uh craig says please tell us of your
fine
nashville dining selections i'm living
vicariously over here
so i only had about we had roughly 48
hours there we arrived really late with
the connecting flight we got there at 1
am what was the name of the place i
wrote it down we went to a honky tonk
on uh oh here we go we went to a hockey
tank on broadway over there and you know
every first off i couldn't believe that
people were out and about no mess and
people were singing and dancing and
having a ball and it was just great
and i'm walking we're trying to find a
place to eat this guy grabs me he's like
dave ruben you got to come in here man
we were at roberts on western world
robert's on western world is that what
it's called
robert's western world uh and they did
have fried bologna sandwich
uh but i i felt that at 1 am uh and i
had
to be you know on camera the next
morning early i couldn't do the fried
balloon sandwich i had a great
cheeseburger though
and you know greasy on the fries and
everything else and then the guy who was
singing they were doing some johnny cash
stuff
turned out he was a fan and a couple
other people and just people were just
having fun and enjoying themselves
and it was just great um and then i only
had one other night and actually
candace made me dinner so unless she's
running a restaurant you can't have that
mark says dave you have killer hair
can you share with us what product you
use
uh so you guys know my my hair has been
an adventure because
as i talk about in my book i developed
alopecia areata
a couple years ago when i first started
getting hate and it's a basically an
autoimmune
situation where your hair just starts
falling out your white blood cells start
attacking your hair follicles they don't
even know why so they can really only
chalk it up to stress
i developed it a couple years ago at one
point i had lost about 40
of my hair i posted a picture about it
was it was pretty miserable i went on
some really awful medications
that caused me to be really bloated and
i looked exhausted bags under my eyes
and itchy and red and gross and it was
really
quite awful what i did to deal with that
was was change how i deal with stress
that was one thing
uh and and um well not spend as much
time online right that had something to
do with the two that's when i started
the august off the grid situation
and and not take so much of the hate so
seriously and and all of that
kind of stuff i also changed my diet
where i went to more of
like a carb-free situation i do as i
said i ate cheeseburgers so i do
some of that but i changed my diet more
stuff
we got a an infrared sauna which are
actually are not that expensive which i
try to do
in the morning every day although i did
not do it this morning because i was
very busy
um but you specifically and in any sense
this my hair all grew back my hair
actually grew back
what product do you use i use oribe
dry texturizing spray it ain't cheap i'm
warning you mark
it ain't cheap but you press this thing
and it's like
boom like it's like the freaking like
force
out of a can and it will it'll get the
hair alive and then i use the
oribe dry uh not dry texturizing that's
what i use for that
the fine fine something hairspray which
is like the softest lightest hairspray
so you're still going to get the nice
bounce
and i can tell you that one advantage of
being in la there's no humidity so you
can pretty much do anything you want
with your hair
nashville is my hair was a little
flatter you'll see that
probably tonight on candace 6 p.m
eastern
on dailywire.com reminder guys part
three of my interview with mark levin
who has been i'm sorry that's 6 p.m
pacific for candace all right okay
um part three in my interview with mark
levin
who has been fighting for so many of the
causes that i have come to believe in
for many many years before me that is up
on youtube right now and of course the
full episode is
up ad free at rubinreport.locals.com the
paul rossi interview the the teacher who
i referenced earlier
liberal teacher mugged by liberalism
that is up on youtube right now
we posted part one it was a busy week
posted part one of my interview with
nikki haley which we did here in studio
my first
in studio interview in a long time we
did a little makeshift situation
but we're gonna work on uh on filling
out the studio and so i can do some more
stuff in person
part one is up on youtube right now
because it was about
the john kerry incident that everybody
was talking about this week this week
the rest of it will be up next week and
for more if you want to play along and
see what i'm eating what i'm listening
to what else i'm doing over the weekend
and just
share good things about life as opposed
to endless politics and hate
uh you can join us at
reubenreport.locals.com and by the way
we've got an ios app so an apple app and
a uh
an android app that you can get on
google play and there's push
notifications and live chat when i'm on
the plane
i was doing live chat with people we'll
be testing out live video streaming i
think in about a week a lot of good
stuff happening
so i hope that you enjoy the weekend i
hope that you've enjoyed
our time together 42 minutes is this the
longest one i've ever done
this might be the longest direct message
i've ever done people
what a day what a day have a great
weekend everybody see you on monday